okay so the ultimate dream is double
chance you mean threesome is that what
you mean
who gets the nuts but you feel bad for
the other girl like she did all that
work for that nut and then yeah I get it
no no I don't feel bad for her I feel
bad if I don't blast that's what sucks I
just busted too fast my head it's never
happened
but I was usually telling like wait for
the next round give me five give me ten
oh you're running it back in 10 minutes
if it's a three bagger it's a new chick
would you really apologize do you ever
like fake nut and just go to the
bathroom no I hate not okay sell me the
apology I'm sorry you're just I won so
long you're so hot and it just happened
I'm sorry like we got a bad day coming
I'm like damn if I just bust fast you
gotta do camp for that bro yeah you
gotta get ready for the most part of
that fresh that new playlist it's tough
you ever have Tim just stand in the
corner and watch yeah give you advice
[Music]
[Laughter]